[Music]
on this Tuesday night open for business
again Newfoundlanders line up to stock
up on necessities it's crowded in there
today
the trouble with transporting supplies
to the province racing to contain the
coronavirus more deaths and new
infections as the US records its first
case staying current with a digital
currency the Bank of Canada's plan is it
competition for Bitcoin and one last
chance for the ultimate home run the
Canadian hoping to enter the Baseball
Hall of Fame
global national with Donna freezing
tonight
Robin Gil good evening and thank you for
joining us we begin in Newfoundland and
the recovery from what's being dubbed
Snowmageddon 2020 crowds of
Newfoundlanders lined up for hours
outside grocery stores in st. John's
waiting to stock up on food and supplies
for the first time since that historic
Blizzard blasted the province the stores
were only open for a few hours and
residents were advised to buy what they
need to last up to two days a state of
emergency is still in place for Saint
John's and schools in the city will stay
closed for the rest of the week but as
Ross Lord reports there are signs people
are turning the corner with their
kitchen shelves becoming empty it's no
wonder some of these shoppers lined up
two hours in advance to buy groceries
for the first time in five days they ran
out of well chase oh yeah
pick up two drinks just here to get some
you know bread milk eggs stick of butter
we gotta get like milk bread like
necessities running out what followed
was a food frenzy of sorts the polite
kind replenishing with purpose after
literally fearing where their next meals
would come from anxiety based on the
provinces remote location and the
blizzards crippling impact on
transportation links to and within the
island we're gonna need to weaken now
because we don't know when we're gonna
get another opportunity so yeah
management this grocery chain says
there's nothing to worry about
warehouses and distribution networks
will keep the supply chain intact
we don't have reason to believe that
we're gonna be in that level of
difficulty in terms of big shortages for
a long term in a province steeped in
hardship and looking out for each other
there's growing optimism we get some
really bad weather and the government
has to declare a state of emergency and
everybody just comes together scenes
like this are common volunteers
shoveling out those who cannot help
themselves come and help this poor lady
oh she couldn't get out to get any
groceries she said
so here we are as soldiers continue
clearing paths and checking on stranded
residents new Verlander's are starting
to reflect on how they endured grateful
for those who sacrificed like health
care workers who stayed on the job for
days on end with their replacements
unable to travel to work a gradual
increase in traffic makes for awkward
navigating in vehicles and on foot but
for the most part there are positive
steps toward a slow return to normal
you're just gonna do the best that you
can this up try to Brenda Barrett's grin
embarrassed
Ross Lord Global News half of New
Zealand's goods including about 90
percent of perishable foods are moved by
transport trucks arriving by ferry
twice a day there are two ferries that
run between Cape Breton and Newfoundland
but only one operates year-round and
once it makes that six to eight hour
journey across Cabot Strait it's another
nine hour drive around the wat Rock to
the st. Johns area we're about a third
of the island's population lives that's
of course when roads are clear and that
hasn't been the case for much of the
past five days geography is an issue in
this disaster in terms of distance
Newfoundland is remote enough but add to
the fact that it's an island and getting
aid to the affected areas has been a
challenge Mike Armstrong looks at how
help is being delivered and how it's
being received
Nova Walsh is calling the soldiers in
front of her home angels after four days
trapped in her home she was freed
Tuesday by Canadian troops without the
help there was no way she could clear
the snow although she did try I did some
myself the other morning I shoveled the
snow in and put it in a bucket throw
down my bathtub but that's it that's all
I could do
their numbers are still growing the
Canadian Armed Forces says by Wednesday
morning it'll have 400 soldiers and
sailors on the ground if their backs are
getting sore there doesn't seem to be
much complaining it's going good it
means great to get out and help the
community you know see people smile and
everyone's happy
anxious be proud to do what we're doing
response to this disaster is a little
like a symphony a lot of different
groups working together as much as
possible in harmony people in need call
a helpline and those calls are triaged
they're ranked in terms of urgency by
the Red Cross and civil security
officials individuals in the st. Johns
area call that call line and their task
gets prioritized and dispatch dies now
responding to natural disasters isn't
the military's main role but it's one
it's performing more and more often this
operation is the 25th in the last seven
years and the help is needed the
Canadian Red Cross says natural
disasters in this country are increasing
in frequency and severity unfortunately
it is the case the impact on Canadians
from these kinds of events is
substantial and recurring the the breach
that we had was on the goal
Jim bass knows what the army can bring
to the table he's the mayor of a
Montreal borough hit hard by flooding
twice in the last three years
soldiers provided expertise and raw
numbers that the city just didn't have
hundreds more homes would have been
flooded bass says if not for the
military and the coordination of
resources for us that worked really well
because the information that we were
giving civil security officials and what
they were transmitting to the Army was
seamless
one thing the soldiers and sailors
helped with is fatigue for emergency
crews for five days and Counting it's
been all hands on deck having the extra
hands has helped my carbs from Global
News the search for a man who
disappeared in the blizzard last Friday
has been suspended
the RCMP says the search for Joshua wall
will resume if any new information comes
to light while vanished after leaving
his home in broaches line during the
storm a close-knit community on
Newfoundland Avalon Peninsula is
mourning the loss of two men who passed
away in the after
of the storm the mayor of Harper Grace
confirmed the sudden death to global
news ad thrilled Albert bud chief a
former town councilor died Friday then
on Saturday
72 year-old Rupert Crocker died he was
known around the community as rocket
both men who were fixtures in the
community were doing physical activity
outdoors before they died at least six
people have died in an outbreak of the
new corona virus which has now reached
the United States the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention has
confirmed the first u.s. case has been
detected in Washington State the patient
who is in isolation recently returned
from Wuhan China where the SARS like
respiratory illness was first detected
last month
authorities there are spraying
disinfectant on the streets and today
the city revealed a series of new
measures in the race to contain the
deadly virus they include the
cancellation of upcoming Chinese New
Year celebrations the busiest travel
season in the country and today the
World Health Organization warned the
corona virus is likely to spread
more cases should be expected in other
parts of China and possibly other
countries in coming days the team from
whu-oh are concluding a mission with
health officials in Wuhan working on the
response to another corona virus at
least 291 people are infected with the
corona virus in China Thailand South
Korea and Japan 77 new cases were
reported yesterday alone
tomorrow the World Health Organization
is holding an emergency meeting to
determine whether the outbreak
constitutes a global public health
emergency there are no reported cases in
Canada for more on the symptoms of the
virus how it spreads and how you can
protect yourself
go to our website global news dot CA /
global national for only the third time
in history the impeachment trial of an
American president is underway in
Washington the Senate began its
proceedings against Donald Trump this
afternoon setting up an epic battle of
her whether Trump should be removed from
office as Jackson prosecco reports even
as the trial gets going there's still
debate about the
evidence it will hear hear you hear you
hear a how the impeachment trial will
unfold the Senate will convene as a
court of impeachment dominated day one
in the Senate Americans do not believe
there will be a fair trial where
lawmakers tried to set the rules
outlining how each side will make its
case although the evidence against the
president is already overwhelming you
may never know the full scope of the
president's misconduct or those around
him Democrats want to hear from
witnesses including White House chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney and former national
security advisor John Bolton both men
have knowledge of the president's scheme
to pressure Ukraine to investigate Joe
Biden the only conclusion will be that
the president has done absolutely
nothing wrong
the president's lawyers have argued
against that while Senate Republicans
use their majority to push for a speedy
trial without witnesses to shield Trump
from further scrutiny the Senate
agreeing to pick up and carry on the
house's inadequate investigation which
set a new precedent that could
incentivize frequent and hasty
impeachments from future House
majorities a trial with no evidence is
not a trial at all it's a cover-up
lawmakers remain so divided they can't
even agree on when to debate the issue
of calling witnesses with the
republican-controlled Senate all but
certain to exonerate Trump their bigger
concern may be ensuring that
predetermined outcome appears at the
very least legitimate Americans need to
believe this proceeding was full and
there and that's the way they will judge
us Jackson what are the chances
some Republicans will ignore party lines
and vote to allow witnesses well Robyn
several have already hinted that they're
open to the idea of hearing from
witnesses but they don't want to make a
decision about that until later on in
the trial it is worth noting that some
Republicans also pushed back against
their leadership today on some of those
other rule matters that came up and
leader Mitch McConnell actually gave in
to their demands so they may have some
leverage here and the rules surrounding
this impeachment trial are tightly
controlled what kind of restrictions do
politicians and the press face
yeah senators can't bring any
electronics into the chamber with them
they must sit in absolute silence for
the duration of the trial reporters to
have faced heavy restrictions there are
no independent cameras or steel cameras
allowed inside the Senate chamber
reporters can only bring in a pen and
paper no electronics and they've
actually lost access to many of the
places where they can normally question
senators on Capitol Hill these are all
rules brought in by the Republican
majority
Jackson prosecco in Washington back here
at home there's a new development in the
race to fill Andrew sheers role as the
Conservative Party leader Quebec former
Liberal premier Josh Weiss says he won't
be making a leadership bid in a
statement he says the Conservatives have
undergone deep changes since I left in
1998 and my positions regarding a number
of social issues are based on deep
convictions the news comes days after
Quebec's anti-corruption Squad revived
an investigation into Liberal Party
fundraising during Sciales tenure the
long awaited trade agreement among
Canada the United States and Mexico will
be ratified next week Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau made that announcement
today on the final day of a three-day
cabinet retreat there was a lot on the
agenda during meetings in Winnipeg but
Trudeau says the new North American free
trade deal will be top priority when
Parliament resumes let's bring in
Abigail Beeman Abigail it's been a long
in that times rocky road to get to this
point Robin as Liberal ministers met
behind closed doors here part of the
focus was how to work in a minority
government and the first hurdle will be
the Canada u.s. Mexico agreement
passing the new NAFTA in Parliament is
our priority millions of Canadians
depend on stable reliable trade with our
largest trading partners from farmers in
Alberta and Auto Workers and Windsor to
aluminum producers and Sagna and
entrepreneurs in st. John's or in
Vancouver the Liberals will need the
support of another party to do it and
today the opposition isn't promising
anything
conservatives say they want to be
briefed throughout the process and
warned they won't rubber stamp anything
the NDP haven't been clear about their
support yet either
and the bloc québécois leader stuck to
his guns he won't support the deal as is
without further protections for aluminum
workers as for what other bills we could
see this winter session the Justice
Minister hopes to table new assisted
dying legislation in February and the
prime minister says some kind of action
on gun control is coming within weeks
but no specifics there nor on some other
big campaign promises such as Pharma
care or how to reach Net Zero emissions
by 2050 Liberal ministers now head back
to Ottawa where the larger liberal
caucus will meet over the next three
days Robin Abigail Beeman in Winnipeg
the remains of one Canadian who was on
the downed Ukrainian airliner had been
returned home Canada says Iran is so far
respecting the victims family's wishes
for burial by repatriating remains but
our foreign minister is still pushing
Tehran to release the planes black boxes
to another country so that crucial data
can be quickly downloaded and there
could be an independent investigation a
hundred and seventy-six people including
57 Canadians were killed when Ron's
military shot the plane down the trend
of going digital
coming up why Canada central bank is
banking on cryptocurrency
digital dollars may be in the works for
the Bank of Canada the nation's central
bank is joining forces with five other
major institutions to study the benefits
of introducing a digital currency as
Mike Lakota reports it comes as more
consumers turned toward electronic forms
of payment
when solid seller mad radish opened in
Ottawa two years ago it tossed cash in
favor of debit and credit only other
businesses have followed and so have
consumers we've just sort of shifted to
that Apple pay and that's been super
handy as well you don't even have to
pull out your credit cards according to
an organization that tracks payments in
Canada 73% of all transactions in this
country are electronic so we're
essentially already a digital economy
the Bank of Canada is now looking at
digital currency the bank needs to think
about other emerging payment
technologies these of course include
crypto assets such as Bitcoin the Bank
of Canada announced today it's joining
forces with five other central banks in
England Japan Sweden Switzerland and the
European Central Bank to study digital
currencies it's hard to ignore given the
emergence of Bitcoin the percentage of
Canadians who own the cryptocurrency
jumped from 2.9 percent to 5 percent
between 2016 and 2017
now most people use it as an investment
vehicle after all one Bitcoin is worth
more than eleven thousand dollars
Canadian but it's highly volatile and
some predict it's days are numbered the
moment that central banks get into
digital currency that will be the death
knell for these private digital
currencies a China is already working on
its own digital currency and social
media giant Facebook is doing the same
it's why business professor Ian Lee says
Canada has no choice but to start
looking at it however he points out our
central bank has to be careful not to
become competition for commercial banks
if they created such an attractive
digital currency they would suck all
that deposit money or blood of it
out of the banking system a spokesperson
with the Bank of Canada cautions these
discussions with other countries are
just exploratory and no decision has
been made yet but when you consider
where our economy already is the central
bank may have to create a digital
currency to remain current Michael
cooter global news Ottawa still ahead a
Canadian team joins Greta toon burg to
call for climate action at the World
Economic Forum
you are watching global national here
stunning footage of a deadly inferno
caused by pipeline accident on Sunday in
Lagos Nigeria the fire burned through
homes in the surrounding district at
least four people were killed but
unverified reports from witnesses
suggest more may have perished officials
are blaming oil fees a common cause for
many pipeline fires in the country a
Canadian teen had a major presence at
the World Economic Forum in Davos
Switzerland today the work we do because
a lot of it 15 year old autumn Peltier
is an indigenous water activist from
Northern Ontario she was part of a panel
that included 17 year old Swedish
climate activists Greta tun Berg the
teens called for action over empty
promises Peltier says young people
deserve to be taken seriously even the
fact that us youth have to be up here
trying to create awareness and make
change I feel I feel it's almost kind of
wrong and we shouldn't be having to do
this it seems like it's it's the climate
and environment is is a hot topic right
now and lots thanks to young people
pushing but of course if you see it from
another perspective or pretty much
nothing has been done since the global
emissions of co2 has not reduced the
invitation only conference brings
together business leaders heads of state
and celebrities this year's theme is
stakeholders for a sustainable and
cohesive world
up next the last chance for Canadian
Larry Walker to slide into the Baseball
Hall of Fame
there's some breaking news in the sports
world tonight involving one of Canada's
greatest baseball players BC born Larry
Walker has been voted into baseball's
Hall of Fame
this was his 10th and final year of
eligibility and as Eric Sorenson reports
Walker had low expectations but his fans
didn't gain the kind of numbers that
he's had initially he was one of the
most natural athletes in the game the
rare five-tool player Larry Walker could
hit and hit with power he had speed and
could field his position with the best
of them as a youngster he thought he'd
be a hockey goaltender only turning to
baseball as a teenager when the Montreal
Expos found him only one Canadian has
ever made the Baseball Hall of Fame
picture Ferguson Jenkins Walker paved
the way for other Canadian hitters and
inspired countless youngsters I've seen
my name on all the top of the records as
far as Canadian more players and I hope
it encourages young kids in Canada to
perhaps take the same Road if their
which desire to do that critics say his
stats benefited from playing in the thin
air in Denver for years still he won
three batting titles was the league MVP
and won seven Gold Gloves if you look at
the people on the ballot he deserves it
he deserves to be named on 75% of the
ballots for Larry Walker the one-time
Montreal Expo and the longtime Colorado
rocky the Hall of Fame looked out of
reach for most of his 10 years of
eligibility to make it at least 75% of
baseball writers had to vote for him for
several years Walker barely hit 20% in
2014 he felt it 10% but as the log jam
of superstars became enshrined in those
years walker's chances improved and with
modern analytics Walker's all-round game
looked better and better
he reached 34% and last year almost 55%
and in this his last year he would need
another big jump Walker needed 75% of
the votes cast his final total he
cleared 76 percent Larry Walker becomes
the first position player and second
canadian-born member
of the National Baseball Hall of Fame it
is one of the most stunning changes of
heart in the history of Hall of Fame
voting more than triple the support
Walker had three years ago from baseball
writers in his last swing for the Hall
of Fame Walker joins the likes of Jim
Rice and another Expo Tim Raines each
voted in in their last year of
eligibility to be enshrined in
baseball's Hall of Fame in his last
chance was like Larry Walker in the
bottom of the ninth one more time he
came through in the clutch
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto well
done that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Robin Gill
tonight your Canada is Canmore Alberta
we would love to see your corner of this
country so email your pictures to
viewers at global national calm thank
you for watching and have a great night
[Music]